so I have a bunch of questions for you
if if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing you'd like them watching
and why first of all I'd like to
introduce myself my name's Adam
um I'm an actor
um I will do any like birthday parties
uh bar mitzvahs I like to just do
monologues either Shakespearean or
modern
um and I'm affordable
49.95 for uh the first three hours and
then 69.95 for every 10 minutes
thereafter
uh other than that
um what would I want them to see to
watch yeah I think party down is a good
place to to start because it was sort of
the first thing I did where I felt like
um like I was doing something
for the right reasons I was sort of in
control of what I was doing mostly
because I was doing it with my friends
and we were doing something that was
really close to
our hearts and and the the the whole
cast really connected really directly
with the material because at the time
you know we started shooting in 2008 and
we were all sort of in a similar place
of you know
successes had been just Out Of Reach for
for most of us and
and uh so we really felt
directly what these characters were
going through we all kind of had our
faces pressed up against the glass A
little bit as a fan of party down and
I've seen the first five of the six
episodes of season three is there any
chance that you guys might do another
season after this or is it sort of like
we just wanted to do this you know what
I mean I don't know I think that's up to
audiences and stars and I think it's a
little bit out of our hands
um you know getting the six weeks where
this group of now very busy people could
all get together and do do the show was
a feat in scheduling and Engineering uh
but we all wanted to do it so badly
um that uh and stars was cool enough to
to bear with us while we figured it out
um that that's always going to be
challenging but we did it once we could
totally do it again I think everyone
would love to to do more but I think
it's you know it's sort of out of our
hands what's the reason for the six
episodes and not more because of
everyone's schedules I think so probably
yeah I think that's that's about
um first of all we didn't want to dump
too much of a workload on John and bomb
who uh writes the majority of of the
season but also yes I think that that's
a manageable period of time for uh for
this group of actors to all the
schedules lining up I think I don't want
to do spoilers but there is an episode
in the first five where everyone gets
high and I'm curious when you find out
that you're going to be doing that do
you get nervous as an actor because you
need to you know play someone high or
are you sort of like excited and relish
that challenge yeah it it is funny it's
definitely like I didn't really get
nervous here because it's this show and
uh you're you're just kind of uh safety
in numbers like
I know no matter what
I'm gonna be protected by this group of
incredible actors so I don't need to
worry as much as if it was me by myself
I think I've kind of found that both
with party down and Parks and Rec that
uh that when you're in a an incredible
Ensemble
um if you know you can sort of hide in
the background and and just be lifted up
by how great everyone around you is
so when it's like we're gonna be high
together that is something that's like
being high or drunk it's always hard
because you don't wanna
be corny and and everyone who's been
hired drunk you don't want them to watch
it and think you're full of and it
it's it's it's fake
um so you know I think we were
we were all cognizant of that and wanted
to
to make it realistic all five episodes
that I saw made me laugh I'm curious if
you had a favorite of those five man
it's I think it's too early for me to
pick a favorite
um
I mean I know that
I think Looking Back Now that it's been
more than a decade I think my very
favorite effort is either sweet 16 or
Steve Gutenberg
um
but it's it's it took a while I think I
need a few years before I'm able to see
a favorite emerge what was it actually
like for you the day before you were
going to step on set to begin filming
had you re-watched the first two seasons
were you in your head a little bit
because it's been a while since you've
played the character
um yeah I didn't watch it right before
um I had watched episodes
um my kids hadn't seen them
so we watched some of them but I wasn't
watching it too close to when we shot I
just didn't want to get I don't know
self-conscious or something so but I
know them I the episodes so well
um and I'd seen them recent enough that
uh that I felt like I was I was ready to
go the first two seasons I know there
were some improvisation uh on set with
season three how was it a similar amount
in terms of
John's writing Amplified like 10 by
people coming up with stuff in the
moment yeah there's never been a ton of
improvisation on on party down
um it's
you know John uh and uh Dan Etheridge
and Rob Thomas sometimes write as well
but it's mainly uh John and and he's a
just an incredible writer and uh you
know here and there there are there are
uh little bits and pieces but
um
uh but it's it's not I I wouldn't say
it's a show that really has a ton of
improvisation in it before I run out of
time with you uh like the entire planet
who's seen it I'm obviously a huge fan
of severance and um oh thanks I can't
say enough about that show it's
incredible
um I know you're in the middle of
filming season two uh how is filming
been going great it's going great I
can't wait to till I can actually talk
about it and and
and uh people can see what we're what
we're doing uh it's but it's it's really
fun it's really really cool when you
signed on for severance did were you
told like we have a three-year plan we
have a Five-Year Plan like how much were
you told about the ultimate Arc of where
everything is going well I think like
any show
um you know you just hope you can get to
the finish line of of of
writing the pilot and then shooting the
pilot and then getting a season and
getting that season on the air and then
getting picked up to make more so I
think you know the Finish Lines
um the potential Finish Lines there's
always a you you there might be a Finish
Line at the end of you know shooting
just one episode so you know we made
season one not knowing if we would ever
make any more
um and so
the fact that we're making another
season is great
um if we get to make more then that's
great too I think there are sort of
variable
um ideas of of where to go with it
depending on how long we get to make it
you got to be part of Madame Webb which
is your entry into into Sony's Marvel
World
um was that something you were looking
for and what can you tease about it you
know I wasn't I I actually didn't think
I was gonna work
um over the summer uh before we started
Severance up again because we started in
October and I thought I I I wasn't
planning on working at all and before
then
and then this came up and
um
and I I I couldn't resist it's really
it's really cool um it's a really fun uh
world and and a great role and uh but I
can't really say that much uh about it
other than
um it's cool and fun which I'm sure
you're so sick of hearing from people I
talked to a lot of Marvel people I
understand the The Dilemma of talking
about it um I gotta stop there I'm just
gonna say man I really enjoy your work
and congrats on getting to do another
season of party down thanks man thank
you